E
FIVE."
♪ ♪
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S AGENDA IS ON
THE BREAK OF A CATASTROPHIC
FAILURE, AND COULD NUKE HIS
ENTIRE PRESIDENCY.
THE UNITER IN CHIEF STRUGGLING
TO UNITE HIS OWN PARTY IN ORDER
TO PASS A MASSIVE REPORT
$5 TRILLION TAX AND GRAB SCHEME
THAT WILL FUNDAMENTALLY
TRANSFORM THE ENTIRE COUNTRY FOR
DECADES.
BERNIE SANDERS TRYING TO PASS
THIS MASSIVE SPENDING PLAN, BUT
MODERATES ARE SAYING "LET'S PUMP
THE BRAKES.
CLOSE QUOTES WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY JEN SAKI IS
DOING HER BEST TO SAVE HER THING
IS FINE.
>> Secretary Psaki: OUR
OBJECTIVE IS TO WORK TOWARDS AN
AGREEMENT.
THAT'S IN PROGRESS.
WE ARE NOT THERE, BUT WE ARE
WORKING ON IT.
I THINK THERE'S A FAIR NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT CONSIDER
THEMSELVES QUITE PROGRESSIVE IN
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
THE ROLE THE PRESIDENT'S PLANE
IS WORKING TO GET 50 VOTES IN
THE SENATE.
LOOKS LIKE THEY ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE THAT ROLE AND PLAY.
WE WILL SEE.
THE DAY IS YOUNG AND.
I'LL KEEP SAYING THAT.
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS ARE EITHER
TERRIBLE AT MATH OR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE TOO STUPID, BY
REPEATING THE CLAIM THAT
SPENDING $3.5 TRILLION WILL COST
NOTHING.
>> President Biden: IT IS $0
PRICE TAG ON THE DEBT.
WE ARE GOING TO PAY FOR
EVERYTHING WE SPEND.
>> THIS IS A $0 BILL.
>> OF THE INVESTMENTS PROPOSED,
INCLUDING TAX CUTS AND THE
PAY -- INCLUDING MAKING THE TAX
SYSTEM WERE FAIR, $0.
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT A DOLLAR
AMOUNT.
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT, AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID, IS $0.
THIS BILL WILL BE PAID FOR.
>> Jesse: SPIRIT,
$3.5 TRILLION, $0, COSTS
NOTHING, DAGEN!
'S BEFORE THEY ARE BAD AT MATH.
NANCY PELOSI COULD GET UP THERE
AND SAY "TWO PLUS TWO IS --" AND
IT WOULD BE MORE TRUTHFUL THAN
WHAT SHE IS SAYING.
THEY THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE STUPID.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE
THAT ALL YEAR OF THE "NO, YOU
DON'T UNDERSTAND," LIKE YOUR
GRANDMOTHER WHEN YOU DISAGREE
WITH HER.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO GET BETTER
AT MATH BASED ON THAT.
THIS IS SOMETHING DANA HAS
TALKED ABOUT WITH ANOTHER
SUBJECT.
IF THIS $3.5 TRILLION PACKAGE --
IT'S NOT THAT, IT'S
$5.5 TRILLION -- AND IT'S NOT
PAID FOR BASED ON THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON TAXATION, ONLY
$2 TRILLION IS RAISED IN
REVENUE.
THESE ARE VAST ENTITLEMENTS THAT
TRANSFORM THE UNITED STATES,
IT'S THE END OF THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
THERE IS UNIVERSAL BY BASIC
INCOME IN HERE, A CHILD TAX
CREDIT THAT WOULD GO ON FOREVER,
GOES TO THE AFFLUENT.
THERE ARE OTHER ELEMENTS IN HERE
THAT CHANGE THE FOUNDATION OF
THE WAY WE WORK AND LIVE.
THE AMERICAN DREAM IS ABOUT
STRIVING AND MOVING UP AND
WORKING HARD.